[Applause]
sly stallone back to work after a wife
of 25 years jennifer flavin filed for
divorce
that's sly surprising fans in new york
city last night with a special screening
of his new movie samaritan out today
it's his first appearance since
reportedly being blindsided by the split
you guys literally cannot live without
one another i think if she was out of
your life with the organizational skills
she has and if she was out of my life it
would be mass suicide exactly which
infers that i have multiple
personalities this is one of the
couple's last joint interviews in
january sharing their differences with
daughter sophia and sistine on their
unwaxed podcast so i do everything so i
do everything from the minute we wake up
to getting him coffee bringing it to him
in bed i make you breakfast in the
morning and then i go through your
schedule and then we you tell a few
jokes i laugh
that's what keeps us going because i
laugh
my husband i've known each other since
1988 if it's over you're you know it's
very difficult to go back to where you
came from that was jennifer with e.t in
just last year the model re-emphasized
she and sly were opposites but her
stance on divorce hadn't changed there
isn't anybody's relationship that is
perfect and happy all the time always
said to us
never rush things like don't rush to
decide to divorce them or break up with
them i mean everybody has their quirks
like yeah i'm very a type and my husband
is not a type so like
he's very messy i'm not so can i live
with messi that's really important
your dad and i are gonna be
home alone so
the 54 year old mom to three also
admitted being nervous to enter a new
stage of life i'm really going to be an
empty nester so what is your level of
stress so it's it's like out of like a
strong nine straight strong nine
hard nine and it's almost like you have
to get to know each other again which is
so so strange
[Music]